OK, let's go next to our caller from the 4
0 3 who's calling today from 4 0 3.
4 0 3, are you there?
Mm hmm. 4 0 3 last chance before I have to
move on.
Hi.
That's me.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Hello.
Yes, I can read you a quick question.
I was just wondering if you are worried about
a nationalist or protectionist slide to the
code with 19 situation.
What kind of a policy would make that evident?
You know what?
I'm not too sure.
I did just recently see a survey that's New
York parents, obviously, they really want
things like summer camps to start again.
But they're really worried about foreign camp
counselors, that type of thing.
I was wondering if you could see the average
American kind of sliding more towards that.
They weren't already on that.
I mean, one direction.
The funny thing about I'll address that directly.
But the funny thing about that is.
There's so many countries that are doing better
than the United States.
So the idea that we're more at risk if there
are foreign camp counselors seems a little
silly.
I mean, I think that in practice it's not
going to be a huge thing because it's very
likely that particularly international travel
is going to remain pretty depressed through
the fall, if not even longer.
That's my prediction.
One area where I'm hearing a kind of nationalist
surge is we have to re nationalize our supply
chain.
So, you know, we can't be getting a ninety
five mass from China.
We can't be getting medical equipment from
this country or that country.
So that is a nationalist push that I've been
seeing, which is we a lot of the stuff we
buy internationally we should be producing
domestically, which of course will make it
much more expensive.
I mean this has always been the debate when
it comes to outsourcing production of stuff.
We always could do it.
We just have an economy based on getting it
cheaply from somewhere else.
I am seeing now more discussion of we've got
to bring the supply chain inside the borders.
Definitely, and I see that kind of that lean
Justin time, you know, you get your product
and immediately it's shipped out.
Yeah.
That could be coming into question over the
next few years, too.
Anyways, thanks a lot for the question.
Big fans show longtime member.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Excellent.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, please don't hang up, because
I will go I'm gonna go back to the phones
so quickly.
You're not even going to know what hit you
right after this short break.